le serpent est parmi nous
ingres et 6 seraient mortes pour expier
ses fautes non c'était un accident dieu
veille sur elle aujourd'hui
une créature marine n'a été repérée dans
les stores et quelque chose là dehors
c'est ce que je suis venu découvrir
j'ai fait un peu de recherche au sujet
d'un animal mythique n'ont pas mis
tikrit est
ce sa pensée c'est une invention un
symptôme de l'époque dans laquelle nous
vivons donc je vous êtes contre le
progrès
je préférais croire en une créature que
des gens vraiment vu quand un dieu
invisible elle semblait je ne
le pousserai pas à vous juger peu
importe jusqu'au vous irez
tout le monde est un peu tendue
actuellement fermez vos portes et vos
prières
s'essayer d'y voir clair de découvrir la
vérité nous devons tous suivre nos
passions je ne peux qu'abonder
j'ai peur qu'ils en ont
pour ça qu'il est si qui est ici
oubliez les sexes redevenez la femme que
vous étiez on croirait que vous êtes
amoureuse tout le monde aime cora
je leur ai fait part vous n'êtes pas à
l'origine de tout ça mon coeur et nos
pensées secrètes nous ne sommes pas
mettre mes raisons de pouvoir
d'influencer notre portée une femme a
succombé à la tentation trompé par le
rebond
ils m'ont accusé de choses horribles et
vous n'avez rien fait je suis le
révérend vous ne pouvez pas être à la
fois mon ami un homme de dieu je suis
incapable d'y voir clair quand je suis
prêt vous mais je ne suis pas coupable
de votre faiblesse amour n'est pas une
faiblesse
on dirait que le serpent de l'essex a
plongé ses griffes
chacun de nos vies dans le doute et la
peur
et le temps est venu pour nous de nous
rassembler n'ayez pas peur c'est quand
nous semblons être le plus égaré
que la source de la lumière et la plus
proche